2000 opposants à la mégabassine de
Sainte-Soline dans les Deux-Sèvres
campent toujours sur place ce matin il
promettent une nouvelle manifestation
cet après-midi pour s'opposer la
construction d'une retenue d'eau de quoi
le pays a besoin aujourd'hui il a besoin
d'ordre bon sang vous l'avez pas montré
dans les reportages qui ont précédé mais
regardez l'actualité hier encore ce qui
s'est passé les manifestations de ce
week-end ont été interdites par les
autorités 1500 gendarmes ont été
mobilisés un certain nombre
d'associations qui aujourd'hui s'y
opposent ont signé le protocole qui
permettait de créer ses réserves de
substitution pour éviter de pomper dans
la nappe l'été et donc il faut que un
moment les choses cessent et que on
cesse des manifestations qui n'ont pas
lieu d'être qu'est-ce que vous voulez
dire par ce mot
baratineur le baratin c'était assez
simple ce sont des mots qui ne veulent
rien dire qui souvent fatigue et le
président de la République pour ce qui
me concerne me fatigue de plus en plus
je me suis avancé vers les forces de
l'ordre avec un autre député France
insoumise qui avait aussi
écharpe on a été directement repoussé et
puis on a pris des coups de matraque
notamment dans les genoux avec
probablement l'intention de nous faire
tomber le soutien encore une fois de la
nuque et des députés d'extrême gauche
qui soutiennent des choses parfaitement
illégales parfaitement
anti-démocratiques contraire à la loi et
on peut s'interroger sur les réelles
motivations de ces formations politiques
qui siègent au Parlement et qui n'ont
que du mépris finalement pour les règles
républicaines là on a eu un déploiement
policier qui était extrêmement important
1700 policiers
et je ne cautionne rien évidemment les
les gendarmes blessés et je leur apporte
même le soutien mais il y a aussi des
manifestants qui ont été blessés je leur
apporte aussi le soutien c'est le retour
à l'âge de pierre les écologistes
voudraient que l'on revienne je ne sais
pas à quoi mais en tout cas pas à ceux
qui permettraient le progrès économique
et le juste équilibre entre protection
de l'environnement est nécessaire
économie et je pense que ça va devenir
oui je pense parce que le très bonne
chose je pense qu'il est bien qu'il y
ait des militants qui occupent les
terrains qui là en l'occurrence c'est un
terrain privé donc ils sont avec
l'accord de la personne qui détient ce
terrain pour signifier que ces
projets-là nous envoient dans le mur lui
il met en cause la police il parle de
manifestations pacifique et puis il y a
cette interrogation sans surprise de sa
part une police républicaine on est
vraiment on ne sait même plus comment
qualifier le scandale que représente les
les insultes de Jean-Luc Mélenchon à
l'égard des forces de l'ordre face à des
gouvernants qui refusent d'agir
réellement pour
protéger la planète pour permettre à
toute l'agriculture et à tous les
paysans de vivre oui parfois il faut
avoir recours à des occupations
pacifiques des lieux à des deux côtés en
plus
que faisait dans cette manifestation
interdite que faisait dans cette
manifestation des parlementaires de la
République que faisait mon collègue
Yannick Jadot que faisait madame
Sandrine Rousseau c'est un peu voilà
ce qui joue la division en permanence
à un moment donné ça gagne rien il faut
que Yannick Jadot entendent que là on a
besoin de
d'aller dans une écologie qui soit une
écologie et de retrouver l'écologie de
combat qui a été l'écologie pendant des
années en permanence si vous parlez
sur la voiture
je parle de son propos comment les gens
qui passent leur temps à nous parler du
réchauffement climatique peuvent-ils
ensuite nous empêcher de nous donner les
moyens de faire face au réchauffement
climatique l'émotion est immense ce
dimanche assez houle les habitants sont
nombreux à venir rendre hommage aux
victimes de la veille un peu plus tôt
vers 22h la fête bat son plat près de
100 000 jeunes sont rassemblés pour
fêter Halloween pour la première fois
depuis la crise sanitaire quand soudain
un mouvement de full créé la panique les
réactions internationales se sont
succédées sur Twitter Emmanuel Macron a
ainsi exprimé une pensée émue pour les
habitants de Séoul et pour l'ensemble du
peuple coréen la France est à vos côtés
Sarkozy n'est pas mon idole on
idole je préfère Brad Pitt excusez-moi